sir Jeju Tim ovitch and Alex tile are in
the Chinese capital Beijing they're not
here on vacation this is their job they
work for Audi tracking down fake car
parts and their criminal manufacturers
today they're headed for a huge market
in the city that specializes in car
parts
thousands of traders sell parts here
most of them counterfeit it's not always
easy to spot the difference sergej says
he's been in the car parts business for
nearly 20 years so he has lots of
experience even early in the morning
business is brisk at the market which
sprawls over several Hector's sera jey
and his colleague Alex parked their car
and explore on foot
sergej explains that they're checking
out shops that deal in howdy parts few
stock the parts on site but the Audi men
hope to find shops with samples and
showcases then they'll try to involve
the salespeople in a discussion the
first stop they noticed those outtie
radiator grilles but everything here is
secondhand a few minutes leader success
seems closed this dealer looks promising
but the Audi brand protectors get
nowhere
they'll help sir J says the man had
nothing on hand and wasn't eager or
cooperative about taking an order maybe
it's still too early they approached the
dealers pretending to be European
importers interested in business their
tenacity pays off finally they find a
dealer who's willing to sell them parts
they say they're interested in buying a
job lot of a thousand parts and take a
sample with them Sergey says the shop
sold them a coolant pump the quality is
poor it's definitely a forgery the Audi
men have a receipt they bought the part
for 151 the equivalent of 20 euros
sergej says they now have a tip that
water pumps like this come from factory
south of Shanghai now they're going to
trying to find those factories and carry
out a major raid on the source of these
parts the victim often and dundas names
becomes activated on the the but the
counterfeiters know the dangers and take
precautions alex says catching the
fortress used to be easier the factories
had public addresses now they produce
more or less underground the factories
go for a low-profile or no profile the
production sites are often small private
buildings with no company name but the
brand protectors still have to find a
way to gain entrance back at their hotel
sergej presents outtie brand protection
manager Robert stoner with the fake-out
II pump to take legal action against the
forgers more is needed than a car part
that fits in an Audi car
he says the basis for all of outies work
protecting its trademark and products as
intellectual property rights so it's
important that those rights are all
registered in the specific case of this
water pump the violation is the use of
Audis trademark for interlocking rings
so it's plagiarism and a trademark
violation and that gives out a basis to
go after the producer days later were in
Wenzel a center of the southern Chinese
automotive supply industry one-quarter
of all the car parts sold in China come
from here half of them fakes thanks to
the help of local authorities the Audi
men are now hot on the track of the
counterfeiting operation the pair have
prepared a joint raid together with the
Chinese authorities on a factory that
counterfeits water pumps and coolant
pumps they're headed for a warehouse
that an Audi investigative firm has
located where they hope to confiscate
the first fake parts about any
government services they arrive at the
warehouse
if the counterfeiters have already
cleared out the warehouse then weeks of
preparation will have been for nothing
but it looks like the forgers weren't
tipped off now evidence has to be found
fast the forgers have disappeared but
the building is full of fake parts some
already packed for delivery others not
completely assembled what a find
Sergi estimates the value of the parts
here at almost 200,000 euros the hall is
quickly confiscated and meticulously
registered depending on the dimensions
of the crime the forgers could face
several years in prison or fines of up
to a million won about 140,000 euros the
investigators also find indications of
where the parts were made after they
enter the premises it's soon clear that
this is indeed the counterfeiting
production site they've long been trying
to track down the workers all seem to
have cleared out but there are hundreds
of incomplete car parts and
corresponding technical drawings sergej
says forget the idea that commodity
forgery in China is carried out by three
people in a hole in the ground
each filing pieces of metal this is a
highly organized Factory with the vision
of labour set up for large-scale output
and the operation is diversified Howdy's
aren't the only coolant pumps faked here
sergej estimates that this factory
produces tens of thousands of water
pumps a year this is a capacity from
19,000 was a pump in your the Audi brand
protectors and the Chinese authorities
work together gathering evidence to make
it hard for forgers to operate Alec says
it's obvious that as soon as the raid
began the boss sent all his workers home
the computers are still on they didn't
have enough time to cover their tracks
they just got out fast so much [ __ ]
focus I don't become in China alone od
has confiscated fake parts worth 200
million euros in recent years and that's
only what's been caught the actual
market must be much greater but more
important than money is safety parts
produced in these makeshift factories
don't even come close to Western safety
standards
sergej says the brand protectors turned
seized parts over to Audi's Quality
Control Department results in the past
he says have often been scary these
spare parts are far from meeting outies
quality standards
starting with product lifetime but there
are also breakage issues on parts that
are relevant for safety so forgeries
cheat the customer in many ways but the
raid aims at more than confiscating as
many parts as possible fuel and Salas
explains that these raids are just an
investigative step to gain information
on who is behind such operations so that
eventually howdy and the police can go
after the bosses it's a never-ending
hunt because when one counterfeiting
factory is shut down new ones pop up but
it's important to continue the fight for
the safety of car drivers all over the
world